le dossier que nous allons ouvrir ce
soir est un dossier plein de sens et
pleins de larmes
c'est en effet le crime passionnel que
nous allons évoquer je sois des crimes
associés à la passion du coup au début
des années 70 voilà comment étaient
définis les meurtres liés aux violences
conjugales
regardez comment cet avocat racontait le
crime de son client
j'ai coché sur le corps de votre femme
vous l'avait embrassée houleux avec
l'idée d'aider des paroles d'amour une
dimension passionnelle retirait du code
pénal dès 1975
mais les mots des journalistes pour
décrire ces crimes avaient du mal à
évoluer
exemple en 1993 sylvie humbert avait 26
ans il y a quelques jours elle a été
tuée de deux balles dans la tête par son
mari avec lequel elle était en instance
de divorce
il pourrait s'agir d'un crime passionnel
comme on en voit plusieurs dans l'année
en 2002 des psychologues étudié à la
manière dont les journaux évoquaient ces
crimes
conclusion des histoires encore trop
souvent romancée voir ironisé ironie
elle est souvent d'être très très
violente 1 par exemple il ya eu l'amour
à mort d'amar il ya sous les grands
titres à ça un amour trop tranchants
donc pour un monsieur qui évidemment a
tué sa femme à coups de couteau ou aussi
vous avez une passion explosive une
passion un patio explosif c'est un homme
qui aime une voix une bombe dans la
voiture de sa femme qui en est mort tout
de même pour accélérer la prise de
conscience
l'observatoire des violences faites aux
femmes comptabilise le nombre de femmes
assassinées par leur conjoint ou ex
conjoint depuis 2005
un an plus tard l'observatoire national
de la délinquance présentait aussi des
statistiques officielles pour la
première fois le terme crime passionnel
disparaissait alors définitivement du
vocabulaire médiatique 24 hommes et 162
femme sont morts suite à des violences
de leurs conjoints soit 186 victimes en
2004 plus de 11 femmes sont ainsi tués
chaque mois par leur compagnon en plus
de ces recensements les violences
conjugales sont aussi associées aux
thermes féminicide une notion défendu
depuis 2011 par jean michel bouvier le
père de cassandre violées et tuées en
argentine
selon lui le féminicide devait entrer
dans le droit français pour qualifier le
meurtre d'une femme dans le cadre de
violences conjugales mais aussi le
meurtre d'une femme en raison de sa
condition féminine se félicite
finalement serait traité comme un crime
contre l'humanité mais une qui ne vise
qu'une ou deux personnes
parce qu'ils ont les amis y est c'est
pas le fait je dirais d'inscrire dans le
code pénal qui changent les choses mais
le juridique c'est aussi des signaux
porte
quatre ans plus tard en 2015 le terme
féminicide entrait dans le dictionnaire
français et même s'il est aujourd'hui
très largement utilisés pour qualifier
les crimes liés aux violences conjugales
il n'a encore aucune existence juridique
en france
[Musique]